as the Fast and Furious franchise begins
its end fastax hits the Nitro in action
and family but with all the car chases
explosions and betrayal the movie is
bound to leave some lingering questions
warning spoilers ahead with Mr Nobody
nowhere to be seen this time around
there's a new leader of the agency who
is also on the hunt for Dominus crew
Ames is a bulking newbie to the
franchise who's more than capable of
fighting in the field and he has some
ulterior motives that no one is aware of
until the final moments of the film Ames
becoming the leader of the agency is
obviously all part of Dante's plan
however it's never really explained how
Ames became the next in line to take
over the agency he's never been
mentioned before and it's a little
bizarre that Mr nobody's kid didn't get
the opportunity to follow in her
Father's Footsteps maybe that's why Tess
doesn't really trust aims from the start
and is constantly trying to get ahead of
his plans still it feels a little too
convenient that Ames found his way into
a position of power so easily and the
film definitely could have done more to
flesh out his rise to the top within the
agency when F9 brought Sean Twinkie and
Earl the fan favorite Trio from Tokyo
Drift back it was a great moment the
franchise was finally celebrating one of
its underrated Gems by the end of the
film the trio is drinking beers with the
rest of the crew at one of Dom's famous
Barbecues in fast X though they're
inexplicably absent and it's kind of
suspicious it seemed like the three were
officially integrated into the group and
given that they've worked with Tom
before they're all clearly on Dante's
radar Dominic Toretto sent us
perhaps a return in the next film and
maybe two if Vin Diesel gets his way
besides there wouldn't have been much
more for them to do here anyway Dante
attacking everyone would definitely give
them a reason to get back behind the
wheel maybe their return will even allow
the franchise to head back to space
which would definitely help to make the
next movie much more epic it's a shame
though that the Tokyo Drift crew has
once again been left in the shadows for
fast X
Cipher has been a pain for Dom for
multiple films now but in fast acts she
acts much more like his ally she warns
Dom of Dante's presence and that he's
taken a lot of her technology and
Manpower she even helps Letty escape the
agency's Antarctic facility after
they've engaged in some vicious
hand-hand combat Cipher is more friend
than foe this time around which begs a
question is she now an official member
of the crew given Cipher's past and the
bad blood that persists between her and
Dom's team that seems like a temporary
Alliance more than an actual team up
Cipher definitely isn't giving up on her
plans for world domination she's likely
helping the team because she feels so
burned by Dante stealing everything from
her Cipher's skill set will definitely
be a valuable asset to Dom as he goes
about trying to take Dante down Han's
decision to go to deckardshaw for help
is pretty noteworthy given their
difficult past let's take some Graves
after fighting off some of the agency
soldiers Shaw is able to provide Han and
the other crew members with some weapons
that will help them reunite with dom
however when Ramsay discovers that Dante
is targeting pretty much everyone that's
worked with dom she realizes that Shaw's
mother Queenie is also on his hit list
this prompts Shaw to arm up and go find
his mother to protect her this is pretty
much where Shaw exits the film and his
plan as well as his future in the
franchise is left a mystery he'll likely
return in a sequel where he'll no doubt
be finding Dante's forces to save
Queenie before working with dom to take
out Dante based on the film's
post-credits scene Shaw may even find
himself teaming up with a former Frenemy
Hopps Ronaldo Shaw is somewhere out
there and fans will just have to wait to
find out what his plan is
one of the most heartbreaking moments in
fast X comes in the film's big finale
sequence in which a grave sacrifice is
made Dom's brother Jacob Toretto
definitely shows much more heart here
than he did in F9 and acts as the cool
Uncle for little B however he is still
haunted by how he's wronged this family
before and so he makes a heroic
sacrifice to save them when Dante's
forces start to overwhelm Dom Jacob
decides to Ram into the Brigade causing
all the cars involved to explode while
this might seem like a definitive death
it's hard not to wonder if Jacob will
actually stay dead but it's tough to
imagine how they could explain Jacob
Escaping The Burning wreckage at least
without sustaining some severe injuries
however this is the fast franchise where
characters always seem to find a way to
return from the dead even when it seems
impossible
Han Ramsey tej and Roman are off on
their own for most of the film after
Dante's bomb in Rome makes him wanted
men however once they're able to secure
a plane they load up some cars and fly
toward Dom to help him out unfortunately
this all ends up being part of Dante's
plan Dante fires an onslaught of
missiles at the team and it causes the
plane to crash and explode just off
frame behind a mountain in fastx really
just wipe out half of the crew the
answer is left unclear but it's probably
no since it all happens away from Dom
and off camera with all the cars sitting
in the back of the plane it's easy to
see the next film opening with a scene
of them driving out of the plane and
down the mountain at the safety it's an
unlikely scenario in real life but this
is the franchise that took a car to
space so nothing is off the table while
it's definitely a gutsy move for past
decks to suggest that half of domp's
crew is perished chances are the plane
crash was just a bluff meant to give the
film's finale more impact
it was pretty remarkable when Han
returned in F9 after being considered
dead for so long but fast X somehow tops
that reveal by resurrecting another
character that was thought to be a goner
a cipher and Letty walked through the
Arctic tundra they eventually come
across a submarine that rises through
the ice and is operated by someone
totally unexpected Giselle after dying
back in Fast and Furious 6 Giselle is
somehow risen from the dead and is going
to help Cipher and Letty Escape their
frozen hell the film doesn't provide an
explanation for giselle's sudden return
so fans will have to wait for the next
film to get their answers it's going to
be pretty interesting to see how the
next film addresses this shocking
appearance from Gisele but fans will
certainly love seeing the character
return we already can't wait to see a
reunite with Han at some point
okay we admit that the sequel doesn't
really need to address this but still
the indestructible bomb in Vatican City
could use some explaining the first part
of Dante's big plan is to bring Dom's
crew to Rome he plans to detonate the
bomb of the Vatican and blame it on them
what the Vatican
wow you guys are going to hell while
Dom's crew has averted disasters like
this before this time their foe's plan
essentially succeeds it's kinda
miraculous if we're being honest the
audience is asked to believe that the
metal casing surrounding the bomb helps
protect it and lets it roll throughout
the city on its own but seriously what
is that thing made of when it gains
enough speed it slices through buses
like butter and it can't even be stopped
by cars ramming into it even when its
direction changes or it runs into an
obstacle it doesn't lose momentum in the
slightest it's even more mind-boggling
how the bomb doesn't explode when it
catches on fire as a metal casing
heating up would surely cause some kind
of reaction Dante must be one hell of a
planner because he somehow found the
most indestructible material to protect
his bomb this whole sequence completely
defies Logic the explosive has literal
plot armor probably the biggest
unresolved question coming out of fast X
is where does the franchise go from here
most of its characters are either in
perilous situations are totally missing
we already know that fastx is the start
of an overarching final story for the
franchise with Vin Diesel confirming
that a Trilogy is on the cards one of
the few people who has all been
confirmed to be in the next movie is the
villainous Dante as we get a glimpse of
his bigger plans in a post-credits scene
at this point we know that Dante wants
to take out everyone who has ever worked
with Dom's crew before however no one
expected that his next big Target would
be luke Hobbs it was seen getting a call
from Dante while on a mission Hobbs was
actually the one who put a bullet in
Dante's father during the heist in Rio
de Janeiro so he's firmly in Dante's
crosshairs Dwayne Johnson and Vin Diesel
have a well-documented feud after the
former WWE star joined the franchise so
his appearance here was a surprise but
it's clear that Hobbs is returning in a
big way and maybe with Shaw out doing
his own thing we'll get a Hobbs and Shaw
sequel as a next film until the sequel
drifts into theaters the future of the
vast franchise is a mystery
foreign